Speaker 1: It's great to welcome Tom Hartmann
back to the program, Tom hosts the Tom Hartman
program and is also author of The Hidden History
Series.
The latest book in the series is The Hidden
History of Big Brother in America, How the
Death of Privacy and the Rise of Surveillance
Threaten US and our democracy.
Tom, always great speaking to you.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, great to be here with
you.
Thank you for inviting me.
Speaker 1: So James Gleich wrote this book,
The Information, and one of the things that
Gleich writes in the book is that for as long
as there has been any communication technology,
think drums to communicate over long distances
in the African savannah.
There has also been the ability to surveil,
intercept, send confusing messages to trick
those wishing to communicate in that in that
method, and you can sort of follow that with
every communications technology up through
today.
When and how would you say that what we might
consider the modern kind of surveillance and
lack of privacy apparatus really got going
in the United States?
Speaker 5: It was in the late 90s, prior to
1996, the internet operated under the same
telecommunications rules as telephone companies,
and this went back to the 1930s.
To this day, if you're on a phone call with
somebody and it's actually being carried over
cell towers, it's not a VoIP call.
It's not a voice over internet call because
the rules for the internet are now different.
But if you're talking to somebody on a cell
tower or on a regular phone for the phone
company to listen in, for the government to
listen in, for any third party to listen in,
they have to have a warrant.
There has to be a legal basis for that intrusion.
In 1996, with the Telecommunications Act,
Section 230 said, we're going to drop that
for the internet so that that's one piece
of it.
The other is another metaphor that to kind
of explain where we're at is that prior to
1996, the rules for people who host sites
on the internet were very similar to the rules.
For people who own disco clubs, you know,
dance venues, bars, restaurants or you're
in your home.
I mean, if you, David, were to put a sign
out in front of your house that said, Hey,
big party on Saturday, come on and just leave
the front door open and you're sitting in
your living room Saturday afternoon.
The sun's going down.
There's there's somebody raping a woman in
the back room.
There's a there's a bunch of people shooting
up heroin over in the corner and there's a
guy in the other back room who is who is selling
illegal pornography and the police bust in.
They would not only arrest all those people,
they would arrest you as the host of the party,
right?
You have a responsibility for what happens
in your house that you know about.
And that was, you know, I mean, this goes
back to British Common Law back to literally
the 10th century.
So Section 230 of the Telecommunications Act
of 1996 said that's still true for your house.
It's still true for a bar.
It's still true for a restaurant.
Is still true for a civic center.
But it's not true for anybody who builds a
house on the internet.
And thus, Mark Zuckerberg became one of the
wealthiest men in the world.
He built a house and he said, Hey, come on
in and have a party.
And he largely ignored the people who were
shooting heroin in the corner and selling,
you know, I mean, they started.
They eventually started cracking down.
Obviously, they were from the beginning and
on the obvious stuff.
But even now, there's just I mean, you know,
this new report, the January six, was largely
planned on Facebook.
And this isn't just a trash Facebook.
I'm not, you know, he's playing by the rules.
And that's the problem.
I mean, you know, when you have capitalism
in a republic, the job of government is to
set the rules so that capitalism can work
in a way that doesn't damage society.
And we have failed in that regard.
And so the
Speaker 1: Republicans during the Trump era
talked a lot about Section 230, and some of
them seemed to think that if the platforms
had greater liability for the content that
was posted that it would benefit the right
in some way, I guess, because they believed
that the left is regularly defaming and slandering
and so on and so forth.
But they seem to sort of misunderstand the
true impact that changing Section 230 would
have, do they not?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I mean, I think the right's
embrace of changes in Section 230 came along
with Donald Trump complaining about how he
was being treated by social media.
Right?
And they thought somehow if they repealed
that part of Section 230, that, you know,
a thousand flowers bloom or something.
You know, I've never seen the logic in Josh
Hawley actually wrote one of the better books
about the horrors of Section 230.
The last half of the book is mostly mostly
a screed about how liberals want to destroy
America.
But, you know, the first part of his book
is a really good description of the problems
and what's going on and why.
And and you know, you've got people like Ron
Wyden.
You know, the my senator here in Oregon, who's
one of the leaders of the effort to change
Section 230, but it is bipartisan.
Josh Hawley is on board, too.
So, you know, back in 1980 or 81, I started
running forums for CompuServe.
Nigel Peacock, who was still my webmaster
and I. He lives in the UK and we were running
forums.
We had like 30 of them, you know, the IBM
PC Forum, the Macintosh Forum, the JFK Assassination
Forum, the UFO Forum, the ADHD Forum.
We had a whole bunch of them and CompuServe
paid us well.
I mean, we had a staff.
We had about 30 people volunteer, but they
weren't volunteers.
We paid them who were working with us.
And it was a it was a fair amount of money
that CompuServe was paying us because this
was before Section 230 and they built this
house.
It was called.
This is before HTML.
This is before the web as we know it today
and copy serve and AOL, we're pretty much
the only game in town.
And so because they had built a house on the
internet, they had a responsibility for what
happened in that house.
And so we were the ones who were kind of the
hall monitors.
And in 1996, when Section 230 passed, basically
they laid us all off.
Mm-Hmm.
That was why they stopped paying us.
Right.
Speaker 1: You could keep working, but we're
no longer going to.
Yeah.
You know that there's progressive, conservative
and libertarian perspectives in terms of opposition
to the sort of surveillance that that we now
know takes place.
But they're they're sort of different principles.
It's sort of like with flat earth you talk
to for flat-Earthers, they all believe the
Earth is flat, but for conflicting and sometimes
very, very different reasons.
And progressive conservatives and libertarians
have different reasons for opposing the practices
that we see now.
Can you talk a little bit about those different
perspectives?
Speaker 5: With regard to Section 230 or just
more, more generally, we're seeing things.
Well, you know, I think to the extent that
and we're seeing this in particular with the
with Republicans across the country tightening
the screws on your right to vote, that the
the for lack of a better phrase, the police
state aspect of because in my book, I basically
bring out two kinds of Big Brother.
There's the state Big Brother, which is what
George Orwell wrote about.
And then there's the corporate Big Brother,
which George Orwell hadn't anticipated and
which is actually, at the moment, far more
aggressive.
Or at least, you know, the tip of the iceberg
above.
I mean, Ed Snowden kind of showed us what
government was up to, but.
So anyway, the right seems to be embracing
kind of the police state tactics with regard
to voting and and would be or generally are
more inclined to to to.
Not so much embrace police state tactics on
the internet, but to say that, you know, if
if the billionaires who are running big social
media sites want to do what they want to do,
they should be allowed to do it.
There's just this reflexive thing against
regulation.
Libertarians pretty much the same thing.
I mean, libertarians, this the Libertarian
Party was a scam was created in the 1940s
by the real estate lobby as a way to provide
a political cover for basically deregulation
of the industry.
And, you know, they thought of it as as as
a scam themselves.
I think it still is to a large extent.
You know, the idea that a country can work
with nothing but the military and the police
being provided by the government and the courts.
But I think most Democrats are slowly beginning
to realize or understanding my party metaphor.
Really, I mean, this is this is really what
it is, is that you have to have rules for
the game.
You know, the NFL defines the rules for football.
And if the NFL went all libertarian, you know,
they they were all Republican as it were.
You know, they could they would probably change
their rules to say, Well, you know, whichever
team gives the biggest contribution to the
guys on our board of directors gets an extra
player on the field throughout the game.
You know, we can we can tweak things if there's
enough money involved and that kind of thing.
That's sadly and that's what they've done.
I mean, there you have Rick Scott's new 11
point plan promoting deregulation of the polluters
because their big campaign donors to the Republican
Party.
So with regard to privacy in the United States,
I think the dynamic is just very similar,
David,
Speaker 1: when it comes to, you know, in
Europe, we've got the GDPR.
California passed the Consumer Privacy Act
in 2018, so at least people know what personal
data is being collected about them.
Are those types of laws significant and impactful?
Or do they give people maybe some kind of
false sense that something is being done?
Speaker 5: They are significant.
They do have impact.
They they these are those laws are why when
you visit websites that want to do business
in California or in Europe, they will say,
Will you accept cookies?
Right?
It's it's like a flag.
It's a it's a way of saying, Well, yeah, there
is something going on here.
We are sort of spying on you or keeping track
of you or, you know, or maybe it's just to
help your experience.
And in some cases, it is actually.
But in any case, I think that that's that's
something that we need to, you know, really
seriously look at is the in particular the
European rules and the one.
There's a whole chapter about this in my book
in Europe that we definitely do not have.
Here is the right to be forgotten.
This came out of a 2018 lawsuit.
Or maybe it's twenty eight.
No, I'm sorry.
I had to look up the year, but you know, there
was a Spanish guy who discovered that whenever
he googled his net, he had gone through a
rough divorce and bankruptcy back in, like
1998 and lost his property, lost his business.
And when he googled his name, he was at a
real, low profile guy.
And when he googled his name, that was pretty
much all that came up and it looked really
bad on him, you know, and it was impeding
his ability to to to get data and find a job.
And so he he asked Google to delete that from
their search.
You know, things that came up when his name
was put in, Google kind of laughed at him.
He sued in Spain, and European Court went
along with him.
And now you've got, you know, this was the
right to be forgotten across Europe, where
if you don't like what is being said about
you on the internet, you can't necessarily
always petition individual websites to take
down the content about you, but you can ask
the search engines to no longer deliver it
to people.
And that's a pretty consequential thing.
And I know a lot of people in the United States
are probably very much appreciate that particularly
people who have been a victim of of, you know,
what's the phrase for when mostly men manner
outing, you know, old girlfriends with porn
pictures and things like that?
Speaker 1: Oh yeah.
What is the term for that?
I don't remember the term.
Speaker 5: Yeah, it's like revenge porn, I
think.
Yeah.
Yes.
The phrase.
Yeah.
So anyhow, that's something that we should
seriously look at as well.
Speaker 1: If.
Last thing I want to touch on if the direction
that things have been.
Going isn't resisted in some of the ways we've
talked about and that you write in the book
what what sort of at the at the tail end of
it, I mean, is it the direction of like the
Chinese social credit system?
You know, everybody has some different idea
of what they believe would be sort of at the
end of this, what do you think would happen
if this goes on a post?
Speaker 5: We already have a business version,
the Chinese social credit system, and there
are companies that brag that they have 10,
15, 20000 data points on every single one
of us.
They know our most subtle preferences.
They know if we've, you know, for example,
if they're providing information to a company
that's trying to decide whether to answer
your customer service, call in two rings or
in two hours, you can tell that company if
you have recently browse the website of that
company's competitors.
So are you one of those people who's calling
in and saying, Hey, I'd like that price match?
Well, you get to wait two hours or if you're
a regular customer of that kind, you know,
just really, really granular data and some
of which could be used to, you know, basically
harass or embarrass people, as well as to
increase the profits of companies.
So and similarly, there are companies that
specifically market, you know, this kind of
social credit score.
And it's not just your finances, it's not
just whether you pay your credit card on time.
It's, you know, whether you've ever been arrested
for drunk driving or whether you've ever been
in an altercation with anybody or you know
how you behaved online.
In some cases, they're selling this information
to employers, they're selling this information
to landlords, they're selling this information
to retail companies, they're selling this
company to companies, you know, just to cell
phone companies and airlines and everybody
else who get calls from customers.
There's the potential for abuse is extraordinary.
And I'm not saying that it's not appropriate
to do that.
You know, if I was a landlord, I would like
to know if the person who wants to rent an
apartment trashed the last one and let dog
poop.
All right.
That's not unreasonable.
But there there have to be reasonable limits
on this stuff, and there are none right now.
Speaker 1: The book is The Hidden History
of Big Brother in America, how the Death of
Privacy and the Rise of surveillance threaten
us and our democracy.
The book's author is Tom Hartmann.
Tom, always appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: Thank you, David, it's always a
great, great honor and pleasure to be here
with you.